hello yeah guys yeah welcome to this
video we're and we don't get a big fast
we should stick to big science they
think we should it's still June which
means more giant balloon lot the more I
say it the more I think it's not yeah
you suck so this one will put you on the
balloon in the balloon in the balloon
the trample on the trampoline right okay
Anna we'll have you go completely inside
the balloon okay so basically and maybe
using the trampoline I'll try and pop
the balloon by jumping next year
sure yeah sounds comfortable yeah
compared to last week sure so here you
find yourself once again getting into a
red balloon yeah just removing the
remnants of the previous balloon okay
you start filling it and then you as it
got bigger you just put your both your
legs in and got and then I G need you in
yeah I remember you are the genie for a
second oh yeah you would think for most
people that'd be an unforgettable
experience
but other people tell you but you for
your fan or anything
don't let James Buckley tell you you've
got fat James but yeah I'm worried about
the pie hey boys getting the balloon
okay I'll get through this there's annoy
the way we shoot because we shoot look
at years worth the videos a time if
you're not feeling fit you're gonna be
that way for the entire year on camera
yeah
[Applause]
ah well my legs in I hate this I thought
how much I don't like get it in the
balloon okay oh yeah the Cheetahs back
currently right because I've been I'm
wearing a thong at the minute right now
jammed up my half I'm ready for the
final stage of insertion okay which is
first of all the shirt comes off it's a
reveal this and then
[Music]
so now this is the underneath view hey
what's happening here shoulder then sell
his in boys he says it pops up bigger
last time it's right way it now I'm just
in this really small balloon yeah oh
this brings back memories
this really does okay so I guess I'll
just just so you around now until it
pops yeah yeah I can take the how is
that all right this is already very this
is so ready
okay I guess
[Music]
well I'm clearly not heavy enough or
strong enough to jump it to break the
balloon you look a bit you look a bit
sad just there on your own in the middle
oh she quite happy yeah yeah it's not
exactly like I'm doing any work wow this
is a bloke in a balloon did you almost
drown a little bit no oh not got out
before so you want have to do that pop
it from the inside I think I think it'd
be good if you went under and jammed
your face like through the front of it
until it popped my face isn't sharp
enough just open your mouth with your
teeth or pocket I get like this cuz the
waiting for a loo in shape but I feel
like it'd be impossible so I would go
under swim to the front yeah I'm just
going to choose phone call if you press
your face to the front really hard and
like kicked off the back as well you
would come straight through like an
arrow say alright let's check your
clearance oh yeah God not getting the
jump run pheasant hawk
it's no pop suit anyway so let's do it
quick and facial expression as you come
through like you've just championed a
womb chop through right give me the
screwdriver get some scissors ready just
in case I can't break through okay good
luck you ready ready guys
[Applause]
[Music]
man I could give it roleplay I'll surely
get my mouth I couldn't I was like screw
this I just read it loads of it leaked
out did it really
yeah was it new skills and they skate it
trapped in there yeah you can see my
face trying to buy it and I just
couldn't I don't want you to take it
upside down let's look like the hardest
because I pissed the way the trampoline
was it was I felt like that I'd have had
to like broken my back to the eyebrow so
clearly you see if he could see the
river I like you know what something I'm
just gonna use mad this is one of the
weirdest sights I've ever seen my age
look at it oh yeah that's why I was like
you know I just snap up in it
this fat deal you actually look like a
baby in the womb it's like that
massive attack again it is that's
exactly it's like Oh
excitedly didn't ya
[Music]
looks like well uh
these cameras are known for their
clarity and detail but you're gonna have
fun anything I'm telling you that wasn't
the detail I want to see here future
version of me is already traumatized
from having to come have to keyframe it
you're gonna be looking at that for ages
explain to the audience what the raw
footage look like if you had to explain
it hey the raw footage I'd say if you
got like a thin napkin right all right
covered it cover the sausage and the a
tennis ball and then sort of slightly
wet it and then it just foot slowly
flicking around you could just see
everything there's nothing left to the
imagination there too well hopefully the
next video will involve just as much
giant balloon but slightly less of
meanness yeah feel free to follow us on
twitter by some merch main channel
second channel and next week in a new
giant balloon video in giant balloon
june yeah it's not a good name